Drivers know that accidents, construction, stalled vehicles...
...and just the sheer number of people on the road all contribute to traffic.
The real culprit, however, is speed...
...or rather, sudden random fluctuations in speed.
When drivers travel at a constant rate, traffic flows freely.
But when even a single driver hits the brakes, the flow is interrupted,...
...causing a chain reaction among the vehicles behind that driver.
A traffic jam occurs when drivers brake abruptly.
This causes the vehicles behind them to slow down or even come to a stop.
Vehicles enter the back of the jam at a faster rate...
...than the slower moving lead vehicles can accelerate out of it.
The result: a traffic jam persists until the volume of incoming vehicles...
...drops low enough to allow the lead vehicles to restore the flow.